welcome to the reason stream I'm Zach
Weiss Muller joined by my co-host Liz
wolf we are live today so if you have
questions or comments please leave them
and we'll get to some of the good ones
already we have a $ five Super Chat
questioning the very premise of this
stream which is titled Can America help
deescalate the in the Middle East Steve
answerers spoiler alert no well Steve
I'm not ready to pack it up yet and go
home because we are picking up where we
left off last week and looking to
further our understanding of the events
unfolding in Israel and the Gaza Strip
and joining us today to help with that
is TR parsey the Executive Vice
President at the Quincy Institute for
responsible statecraft a DC foreign
policy think tank that aims to promote a
more restrained US foreign policy he was
previously
the head of the national Iranian
American Council and author of the book
treacherous Alliance the secret dealings
of Israel Iran and the United States and
he recently published an article
imploring the Biden Administration to
step up efforts to deescalate the
conflict in order to avoid sparking a
larger Regional War Trea thank you very
much for talking with us today thank you
so much for having me I want to begin by
reading a couple sentences from that
article there is a palpable fear that
the conflict will escalate into a
region-wide war none of the main actors
with the possible exception of Hamas
want or benefit from such a war yet all
sides are acting in a manner that
increases its Risk by the day in what
ways are all sides acting recklessly at
this moment in your view
well if we first take a look at it I
don't think the Iranians or Hezbollah
wanted a war here if in fact the
Iranians were behind this which was an
early reporting that was debunked rather
quickly then it made no sense for
Hezbollah not to attack Hamas
simultaneously from the north um the
Iranians just came out of more than
several months 7 eight months of
protests they barely made it out of that
they're extremely unpopular at home
their economy is in shambles they cannot
afford a war a war in this case would
not be a distraction it would be
something that really would go uh
against their interests because the
population is already quite um by and
large not everyone of course uh
skeptical of the manner in which Iran
has involved itself in this issue and
believe that Iran should use its
resources at home rather than on funding
Hamas or Hezbollah um same thing with
Hezbollah I mean the situation in in in
Lebanon is a complete economic disaster
political crisis Etc nor do the Saudis
want this the Egyptians absolutely do
not want this I don't think the United
States want I genuinely don't believe
the Biden Administration is looking for
an escavation I even don't think that
the Israelis want this they may want to
go after Hezbollah after they're
finished with Gaza assuming that they
actually can be successful but the idea
of having a region wide war with several
fronts at the same time I don't think
they want but who was actually acting in
a restri St manner to make sure that
that scenario does not happen take a
look at for instance Israelis they have
mobilized 350,000 people you don't need
that many to invade Gaza so if you're
sitting in in Lebanon with Hezbollah
your assumption is going to be that
Israel is preparing for an invasion of
Lebanon now the Israelis may not be
planning that at all they may be
mobilizing those people to
deter Hezbollah from intervening in the
conflict to be ready for it rather than
necessarily signaling that they're
actually aiming to go after Hasa and
invading Lebanon but because of these
security dilemma and the misperceptions
and because of the fact that what the B
Administration is doing is to solely put
pressure on Iran and Hezbollah in order
to try to deter them from into being
which I think is fine but the problem is
that that is all that they're doing
there is no such pressure on Israel for
it not to escalate the British press is
reporting today that Biden in in private
talks with the Israelis gave them the
green light for a land invasion of Gaza
we know that a land invasion of Gaza is
the most likely thing to trigger a a
Lebanese intervention through Hezbollah
which would then trigger an Iranian
involvement which in turn would trigger
an American involvement if our objective
is to prevent that and prevent the
United States getting dragged into
another War then we have to do much more
than just deterring the irans we also do
need to put pressure on the Israelis and
there's very little signs that that has
happened so far and just take a look at
what happened this morning the US
Embassy in Lebanon issued a statement
urging all Americans to leave
Lebanon that's not a you
know statement that you make easily it's
a statement that reflects at least a
significant expectation on the American
side that this is going to lead to a
region-wide war and it's better for
Americans to leave Lebanon before that
happens there was a I wanted to play
that I think encapsulates the argument
as to why some people believe Israel
should do a land invasion in Gaza and
why it's necessary for them to do
everything possible to eliminate Hamas
uh the clip I'm going to play is from
Ben Shapiro who I think recently
encapsulated the argument he said they
should show basically no restraint in
finishing off Hamas as he puts it and
the US should offer material support and
then he lays out a series of escalating
events that isn't all that dissimilar
from what you lay out in your article as
to what how this could spill out to uh
into a bigger conflict let's roll that
clip and I'd like to get your
reaction so the real risk for Israel in
not finishing off Kamas right now is
that this is taken as a sign of weakness
as it certainly would be byah heah is a
far more dangerous terrorist group than
Kamas Kamas is a dangerous terrorist
group they just proved it by killing
1300 Jews Hezbollah currently has over a
100,000 highly sophisticated Rockets
aimed directly at the North of Israel
estimates suggest that wereb to fire all
of those Rockets we wouldn't be talking
about 1300 dead Jews You' be talking
about somewhere between 20 and 30,000
dead Jews day one ifah gets in Israel
will have no choice but to unleash the
Air Force if they unleash the Air Force
they're not going to be worried at that
point about civilian casualties at all
they are simply going to have to
eviscerate the entire south of Lebanon
and topple the regime in Lebanon that
supports Hezbollah if that happens Iran
undoubtedly gets in and so does Syria if
that happens and Israel is now faced
with a with a full war in the North
combined with a war in the South because
they will not have defeated Kamas that's
the predicate if Israel is forced to the
wall the possibility of nuclear exchange
is extremely high that is why it is very
important that the United States provide
the material Aid to Israel and that they
also dissuade kah from getting in it's
why Joe Biden has been warning heah not
to get
in what's your what do you think of the
Doomsday scenario that he lays out there
and what is your prescription on how to
avoid such a horrific
scenario there's part of the escavation
that I agree uh you know some of the
logic there I think is valid he talks
about a nule nuclear exchange I don't
really understand what that is because
it's only Israel that has nuclear
weapons Iran does not have nuclear
weapons Hezbollah does not have nuclear
weapons so I don't know what the
exchange there really would be but the
main problem I have with that analysis
is the fundamental premise the idea that
if Israel doesn't destroy Hamas
eliminate Hezbollah will view that as a
sign of weakness that type of sign of
weakness argument is what we're hearing
all the time in order to justify
completely sens escalations that have
been utterly success unsuccessful the
United States went after the Taliban and
Al-Qaeda rightfully mindful of
al-qaeda's attacks on the United States
of 9/11 but some way somehow that
objective of taking out Al-Qaeda or
punishing at them there in
Afghanistan you know changed into a much
larger objective of bringing democracy
to Afghanistan and complete completely
ending evil and things of that nature
which led to a 20 year long
unsuccessful extremely costly occupation
of Afghanistan and guess what the
Taliban are still in charge in kabo so
for Israel to try to do the same which
he has tried before and failed seems to
me be extremely unwise and in fact
rather than Hezbollah looking at that as
a sign of weakness if Israel doesn't do
so it will be a sign of actual wisdom of
recognizing what is not achievable and
pursuing a much more strategically wise
strategy of being able to protect Israel
without falling into the trial uh and
this fear of looking weak only the weak
fear looking weak if you're actually
strong you're not worried about those
things I mean but then by that logic
like what should Israel be doing what is
Justified well first of all killing
thousands of Palestinians that don't
have anything with Hamas doesn't do
anything to punish Hamas and doesn't do
anything to actually add security to
Israel I agree with that but Hamas puts
them in a very difficult position in
terms of using human Shields right well
it's not a question about human Shields
that area is so heavily populated that
you can't go and and do Mass bombings
and expect you're going to hit Hamas
people and not hit civilians uh the
larger problem of all of this and this
is very interesting I had conversations
with Israelis just immediately after
this happened is that Israel was under
the very false belief that it could
sustain an occupation of
Gaza indefinitely that it would bring
about small uh increases of instability
some skirmishes every two or three years
but overall it would be manageable and
as a result you did not need to resolve
the Israeli Palestinian conflict because
this could be managed that belief has
been completely shattered because Hamas
went in and killed more than 1300
Israelis that is not a cost that Israel
can absorb and find acceptable as part
of a broader occupation strategy it is
also incidentally part of the assumption
that the United States made by thinking
that it's going to go for a
normalization deal between Israel and
Saudi Arabia by completely ignoring the
Palestinian issue the world may have
forgotten about the Palestinians the
Israelis the United States a lot of the
Arab Elites very much so but the
Palestinians have not forgotten about
the Palestinians and now they have
reasserted their relevance in the most
most horrific way so you actually need
to go for an actual solution of this
conflict which does not entail some sort
of a military um elimination of the
other side keep in mind Israel was very
much part of funding and bringing about
Hamas as part of a strategy back in the
1980s to play Hamas a religious radical
organization against the PLO which
Israel at the time saw as a far greater
threat playing these different games
have only cost a a lot of people's lives
on both sides and is not bringing about
any type of solution by now 50 60 70
years into it we should have understood
that I very much agree with you in terms
of mourning the loss of Palestinian life
I mean the fact that so many innocent
civilians so many children have been
caught up in in something uh you know
have been senselessly killed by IDF
forces it is a completely unacceptable
thing and every morning I write reason
Roundup which covers this uh I think it
is important that people start these
conversations with more this loss of
innocent life because Israeli life and
Palestinian um has been you know
terribly lost but I do think you're not
fully tackling the question headon of
what should Israel do given that on
October 7th 1300 mostly innocent people
were slaughtered uh you know Holocaust
Survivors babies families all Sheltering
together it's not like Israel is
realistically going to say oh well now's
the time for diplomacy and to really
hammer things out like surely there will
be a military response and so what are
they justified in doing I mean you at
the beginning of this conversation also
said the activating 350,000 360,000
reservists is you know an unacceptable
way to respond to this and that that's
more manpower than they really need but
I'm curious from a more concrete place
what should Israel be doing right now so
let me first uh say something in terms
of uh the loss of life I agree with you
fully on that and I think at the same
time it is realistic to expect that
there will be some sort of a military
response after such an attack whether
those attack such a response is within
the realm of international law Etc we
can discuss separately but the
expectation that there would have been a
response I think is quite clear this is
unfortunately the way most countries do
react to horrific attacks of this kind
but I had this conversation with an
Israeli security expert earlier this
week and and he insisted to me that look
the idea of taking at Hamas that's an
possibility that's not what this is
about so as what this is about that said
well this is about revenge Israel is
filled with rage because of what Hamas
has done and this is about revenge okay
if that is what the ca the case is you
asked you know what should Israel do
well what has Israel already done
there's already more than 4,000 people
killed at what point is the Revenge
satisfied and if it is only revenge and
let's also be honest about the fact that
it may be an Impulse a need to do
something because of the
but let's not pretend that it's actually
adding security let's not pretend that
it's bringing a solution so I I want to
say that in the sense of saying you know
debunking the idea that the other side
who's arguing in favor of these military
uh interventions have a solution uh they
don't they have a Revenge plan and a
Revenge plan at the end of the day is
going to leave a lot of people killed
but it's not going to bring about a
better situation if you truly want to
get to a secure situation you do have to
start NE negotiations I understand
clearly that this is not the right
moment in which anyone on either side is
going to be open to it but the first
step is deescalate get a ceasefire Hamas
is holding more than 200 hostages those
have to be released they have no right
in taking those hostages those have to
be released the United Nations had a
resolution in the security Council
yesterday introduced by Brazil it close
us Ally it condemned Hamas it condemned
Terror ISM in the strongest possible
words it called for the hostages to
absolutely be released right away and it
also called for a humanitarian pause it
did not even mention Israel it didn't
single out Israel the United States
under theide Administration still veto
that resolution how can we say that this
is a path towards a better future for
all of the people in that including the
United States the V thing is well the
Vengeance thing is one possible theore
IAL explanation but what about if we
take seriously the idea that wiping out
Hamas is actually the goal then what
types of things are Justified or is that
just an untenable Theory to you it's not
that it's not uh you know that some
people are not saying that it is a goal
they are saying that it is the goal but
I've never seen that goal be able to be
successful again we tried that 20 years
in Afghanistan with a group that is not
even as close as sophisticated some as
these other groups as as Hamas is for
instance so it's not about whether it is
some a goal that you can justify as a
result of the horrible thing Hamas has
done it's whether this is actually a
realistic thing that ultimately is going
to bring about a better situation for
all sides including of course for these
raes so I can understand the impulse I
can understand the Revenge um uh desire
which unfortunately is part of humanity
but we have played this game many many
times and we're not seeing it leading to
a better situation and at some point we
have to have have the conversation
because it's it's it's not going to be
correct for us to constantly do this and
and 20 years afterwards laugh about how
you know why wasn't the United States
more uh realistic about how to react to
the 911 what we're having that situation
right now are we going to learn from
that wisdom are we going to tell a
friend as in Israel about our experience
and caution them not to repeat the same
thing given the fact that the idea of
actually eliminating Hamas is extremely
unlikely and the human cost in doing so
is not just the thousands of people that
have been killed right now but thousands
and thousands more both on the Israeli
and the Palestinian
side I I want to put some more I want to
put the discussion around ceasefire or
deescalation in a the US political
context you in your article you link to
this fact that there was a state
department memo telling diplomats not to
impress
materials reference these three specific
phrases
deescalation ceasefire end to violence
Bloodshed and restoring calm and I think
that the reason there's so much
hesitance to talk about ceasefire is as
as you mentioned in that UN
resolution the demand is that Hamas
needs to return the hostages that
they've taken and it does strike
Israelis and supporters of Israel that
until that happens that that's the order
of operations until that happens there's
not going to be anything like a
ceasefire is there anything to that idea
that really to get this going in the
right direction Hamas needs to take the
first step and start turning over those
hostages
immediately that's not the way these
things work unfortunately every time you
end up having a release of hostages and
return for ceasefire or whatever the
other ask is on the other side it
happens as a result of diplomacy taking
place there is simply zero trust between
the two sides so neither side is going
to unilaterally take such a step in the
hope that the other side is going to
reciprocate that can only happen if it's
a part of a negotiation the UN has
offered to help with that this is
something that actually the United
States could have also done through
Qatar through Egypt and others that do
have a dialogue uh with Hamas those are
things that could be done in my view
should be done and even if the United
States wouldn't want to do it what is
the signal we're sending to the rest of
the world not only instructing our
diplomats that they cannot talk about
ending the Bloodshed but also we're
vetoing a resolution that is actually
condemning terrorism and condemning
Hamas and calling for a humanitarian
pause which is part of a release of
these
hostages let me take it back to the us
perspective and interest here as well
okay we can you know because part of
what um um the gentleman that the clip
that you showed uh was saying is very
much Venture is very much uh part
of um you know you know the calculations
that may very well exist on the Israeli
side I think the calculation that should
be existing on the American side is that
if these scenarios and it doesn't have
to go as far as Ben put it if these
scenarios go forward and you do have a
land Invasion that triggers Hezbollah
intervention and hezbollah's involvement
will definitely be seen in Washington as
Iran's involvement it may also trigger
Iraqi militias starting to attack
American bases throughout the Middle
East particularly in Iraq there's
already been some drone attacks this
morning against an American base then
then the us is going to get dragged into
this war some people are saying well it
won't be any Grand troops doesn't matter
there's about 50,000 US troops in the
region already there are going to be
sitting targets and they're going to be
targeted by this so in the midst of a
crisis in Ukraine in the midst of a
potential crisis with China over Taiwan
we simply cannot from a US interest
perspective afford yet another war in
the region with these maximalist goal
with with no Exit Plan we've already
been there it would be a stunning
stupidity to allow us to get into that
situation that's why I think the
deescalation priority has to be priority
number one and I'm not confident that
the approach that the Biden
Administration has pursued is sufficient
to achieve that and I think that could
end up being a dramatic disastrous
mistake well I I want to dig a little
bit more into what that approach is
Biden was in Israel on a Wednesday
meeting with the Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and he made some remarks after
that meeting let's play those remarks
and get your analysis of what he's
saying
I come to Israel with a single message
You're Not Alone we're going to make
sure we have what you have what you need
to protect your people to defend your
nation for decades we've ensured
Israel's qualitative military Edge and
later this week I'm going to ask the
United States Congress for unprecedented
support package for Israel's defense I
understand and many Americans
understand you can't look at what has
happened here to your mothers your
fathers your
grandparents Sons daughters children
even babies and not scream out for
justice justice must be
done but I caution this while you feel
that rage don't be consumed by it after
9/11 we were enraged in the United
States while we sought Justice and got
Justice we also made mistakes the vast
majority of Palestinians are not Hamas
Hamas does not represent the Palestinian
people Palestinian people are suffering
greatly as well we mourn the loss of
innocent Palestinian lives like the
entire world I was outraged and saddened
by the enormous loss of life yesterday
in the hospital in
Gaza based on the information we've seen
to date it appears a result of an errant
rocket fired by a terrorist group in
Gaza today I asked the Israeli cabinet I
met with for some time this morning to
agree to the delivery of life-saving
humanitarian assistance of civilians in
Gaza today I'm also announcing $100
million in new US funding for
humanitarian assistance in both Gaza and
the West Bank this money will support
more than 1 million displaced and
conflict affected Palestinians including
emergency needs in Gaza must keep
pursuing peace must keep pursuing a path
so that Israel and the Palestinian
people can both live safely in Security
in dignity and in peace for me that
means a two-state
solution so there's a lot packed into
that Montage of highlights but what I
hear Biden saying is that America will
keep funding Israel's military defense
that he's working to provide Aid to
Palestinians telling Israel not to let
rage Cloud their wartime judgment and
that he still believes in a two-state
solution what are your reactions to
Biden's comments and what are your
critiques of his overall diplomatic
approach I think that Biden says a lot
of very valid things in this interview I
think it is quite helpful that he has
raised the example of our own conduct
after 9/11 and acknowledge mistakes and
missteps that were taken and excesses
that were
taken uh I think it's also valid for him
of course to validate that they're
suffering on both sides here's where I
have a problem on a rhetorical level
many of the things that ven is saying in
my view are correct and are the right
things to
say on a practical level are we actually
doing those things he says that he
believes in the two-state solution the
United States is long abandoned actually
putting any pressure to make sure that
there's an achievement towards that it
was quite interesting in the New York
Times article that Tom fredman wrote
when the B Administration was was trying
to get a normalization deal between
Israel and the Saudis and what was in it
for the Palestinians was not a
compromise that would give them the
state that they've been seeking for more
than 70 years now but rather a pathway
to keep the option the dream alive so
we've gone from actually promising to
achieve a two-state solution to
promising to achieve the survival of the
dream of a two-state solution so we're
not doing those things that the
president is saying and and again the
the normalization deal was premised on
the idea that you can just ignore the
Palestinians that you can as Jared
Kushner said because this is all built
on what Trump's uh Abram Accord was that
you can move beyond the Palestinian
issue not even a desire and ambition to
resolve it but you can move Beyond it
because that conflict has now become so
contained that we don't have to bother
trying to resolve it in essence and in
practice that has been US policy the
rhetoric has been that we still believe
in a two-state solution etc etc part of
the reason why we still say that we do
is because it sounds good and the minute
we say that we don't when we recognize
that we have also helped kill the
pathway for a two-state solution that's
when we would have a very active uh
crisis even in short of what Hamas did
here so we keep on saying it but it's a
pretense game we really do have to shift
being serious about this particularly
mindful the fact that that instability
has a significant likelihood of sucking
the United States into a conflict that
we should not be involved in military so
say a two-state solution gets pursued
what indication do we have that Hamas
would in any way agree to that play this
out for me a little bit well first of
all Hamas is not in control of the West
Bank they're in control
of sure would agree in terms of like
like the way tensions are right now why
do we think that that is what would be
happening well you're saying that right
now but why didn't we do it three four
weeks ago why didn't we do it during
this entire period in which we didn't
have this instead we just gave lip
service to the two-state solution and
continued to pursue a policy that
essentially buried it in the ground
you're quite right that under the
current circumstances it's going to be
extremely difficult to just get any
diplomacy going uh but that is
nevertheless ultimately where we have to
end up uh and that and these moments are
the extremely difficult moments in which
you have to set your Ambitions a little
bit more realistically it has to be
about deescalation ceasefire once you
have that it creates a bit of a pause
that creates political momentum to
escalate it towards a bigger political
agenda and then move towards a real
negotiation to actually end this
conflict it's not so that tomorrow there
can be a meeting with all of these
parties at the table and they would
actually talk about this issue there's
several preliminary steps that need to
be taken if we don't take however we
will never get to the point of actually
having the real diplomacy and we will
also not have the deescalation that can
keep the United States out of this War I
have to assume that this such a
negotiation would involve the
Palestinian Authority cooperating with
Israel and partners to facilitate the
complete expulsion of Hamas because
there's no way that we're coming out of
this
on the heels of a brutal terrorist
attack giving a with you know giving a
two-state solute giving an in an
independent Palestine that it that would
just send the message I I would assume
that terrorism works and acceptable
method of
negotiation I think the pathway here is
to First recognize that there needs to
be uh a negotiation uh with the palan
Authority who by the way incidentally is
lacking significant legitimacy amongst
Palestinians as well uh the majority of
Palestinians in the West Bank tend to
see the Palestinian Authority
essentially having taken over the
management of the occupation and
collaborating with Israelis in that kind
so it's not as if you know uh there's a
partner there that has the backing of
its population and that further
complicates matters but I can see a
pathway in which there is first a
negotiation that I actually gets serious
about a two-state solution and such a
two-state solution has to deal with what
the United States used to call illegal
uh settlements on Palestinian territory
we have significantly softened our
language and our opposition to that even
though those are violations of
international law and even though they
have made uh prospects of a two-state
solution far far less likely we have
green light at that which again is in
practice we're moving in a direction of
making a two-state solution uh next to
Impossible but rhetorically we still
talk about as if that is our goal but
that that sort of dodges the question
that Z that Zach just asked right like
there would be this problem of if you
know ultimately we there there was a
two-state solution that was pursued and
and and granted and gotten that would
send the message I mean you you have to
fully Stamp Out Hamas before that no no
hold on let me let me get clarification
what do you mean that there was a
two-stage solution um that was there no
no no I'm saying if if there were to be
a two-state solution in the aftermath of
this surely one of the stipulations
would have to be that Hamas can in no
way exercise any power within this
region because otherwise there is this
message sent of you know you commit
terroristic acts and get rewarded for
your efforts right like certainly uh
yeah no I I sorry I better understand
the question now thank
you uh so uh first of all let's let's
recognize that in the past negotiations
the West Bank and Gaza oftentimes have
been separated let's also recognize that
if there actually is a valid process
that is genuinely moving towards a
two-state solution guess what that does
it delegitimizes Hamas Hamas is managing
to get a degree of support precisely
because there is no diplomacy precisely
because there is no uh the
implementation of the measures that
Israel was supposed to do were never
implemented and instead we've seen an
increase of settlement activity and the
de facto annexation of Palestinian
territory so there's a clear perception
in the region that that diplomacy did
not yield what it was supposed to do and
then that further gives legitimacy and
support for a rejectionist organization
like himas who was opposed to that
posess from the outset if you actually
truly want to get rid of that type of a
radicalism by being able to have an a
genuine process that is genuinely
seeking a solution that's the best way
of weakening Hamas and then after that
then you know that dynamic in and of
itself can create new opportunities in
uh in Gaza um uh that can help get the
Palestinian population themselves there
get rid of Hamas and get a leadership
that is willing to participate in a
process but right now given the track
record of uh how negotiations have been
used to expand settlements that is right
now not not something that has a lot of
buyers amongst the Palestinians and this
is what I'm saying we have to completely
reverse this if we truly want to get a
resolution here the Assumption had been
this is okay there's never going to be a
major amount of violence and
destabilization here because we have
managed to contain um uh the
Palestinians we have managed to contain
their aspirations we have ai and all of
this technology they can never do
anything else so the cost of just going
on with the status quo and the
occupation is manageable and that was
fundamentally disproven would you
explain the annexation is isue uh to our
audience a little bit I think that's an
interesting thing to bring in and I know
you have some knowledge of that yeah so
the Israelis uh the the division that
was made uh when the Israeli mandate was
created um back in 19 uh late
1940s um had a two-stage solution of
course there were several different Wars
the the Israelis were successful in
those Wars they occupied a lot of those
different territories and then in the
1970s a project began incidentally
partly led by Ariel shaon that said that
for security reasons uh Israel needed to
start populating these parts of the
territory that actually belong to the
Palestinians others were pursuing it
from a religious standpoint uh for
instance hebh horn is is an area in
which you have settlements that has a
significance in the Jewish tradition
those have grown they grown
exponentially During the period of the
negotiations even though they were
supposed to be
dismantled um and that has led to a
scenario in which uh the Palestinian
territory is no longer continuous it's
cut off in so many different parts by
settlements and Roads and checkpoints
that the Israelis put in place in order
for to facilitate uh transportation
between the different settlements so the
Palestinian territory that used to be
continuous is no longer such and that is
that is some of the facts on the ground
that is so-called that has made a two-
State solution so much more difficult
because it either requires uprooting of
all of these settlements and some of
them have now been there for 30 plus
years or or it means that there's going
to be a Palestinian state that is as
they call it just a complete ban it is
not a continuous territory and a
completely impossible to go we should
not be here in the first in the first
place many of the mistakes that we
committed and the status quo that we
accept it has led us to thisen I want to
bring us back to the US's role in all
this for a moment because obviously the
the history of the region is incredibly
complex the question I want to get at
here is what the US should be doing if
anything to facilitate these Solutions I
mean you Biden mentioned in that clip
that he's he's requesting a hundred
billion dollars in foreign aid that and
that's to be split up between Israel
Ukraine and Taiwan uh about according to
reporting from The New York Times the
package is expected to include about 10
billion in mostly military assistance to
help is real 60 billion for Ukraine and
this would cover supposedly a full year
and insulate security funding from the
partisan spending battles that we see
playing out in
Congress what
exactly do you think that America's role
should be in funding any of these
governments in the Middle East um you
know you
mentioned the rise of Hamas earlier that
there that
arguably they you know the US has some
complicity in that you know we talked
with Max Abrams last week a little bit
about how the Israeli far right and
Hamas kind of had this symbiotic
relationship that squeezed out
negotiation negotiators in the middle I
just sometimes wonder like what do what
does America get for pouring all this
money into the region and so what what
what is the appropriate use of foreign
aid from the perspective of the Quincy
Institute which has a more restrained
foreign policy and does not want wants
the US to orient
around you know s basically it's its
self-interest so I I think that's a
great question and I would say that if
you're pouring money into a policy that
is strategically unwise and on very weak
in the first place then you should not
have the expectation that that money
magically is going to fix fix things
that however is not necessarily the same
as saying that uh some degree of for8
cannot be helpful or that that is
inherently problematic I think there's a
lot of money that is going around right
now that should be revised and you know
Revisited um uh in many different ways
but um there's it can also have a very
stabilizing effect if it is part of a
strategy that in and of itself is is
stabilizing and I think unfortunately we
have pursued for more than 40 years a
belief and a strategy that is centered
on the idea that we have to dominate the
Middle East militarily and if we don't
it's going to lead to chaos and Anarchy
in the region and if for our own
security and for the security of the
region as a whole we have to be the
dominant power the track record of that
policy I think is disastrous in 1998
there were five armed conflicts in the
Middle East by
2020 after two decades of that policy of
American domination the number of
conflicts in the region had increased to
22 it's not all America's fault in any
way shape or form but it is happening
during a period in which we're pursuing
that strategy of
domination and some have argued that the
attack of Hamas is an indication as to
why the US need to
re-engage uh in the region and and have
a greater military presence Etc I I
think that's I I don't understand the
logic of that because I think frankly um
our military domination in many senses
actually cemented certain conflicts it
also led to a scenario in which some of
the states that thought that they had
America's protection ended up acting
acting more recklessly than they
otherwise would have precisely because
they thought that whatever they do the
United States is going to come out and
bail them out afterwards so take for
instance Saudi Arabia's conduct and the
you know the bombing of Yemen Etc part
of the reason why Saudi Arabia has
shifted in the last two three years
towards far greater diplomatic
engagement normalization with Iran
resolving the conflict with turkey
resolving the conflict with Qatar Etc is
precisely because the Saudis came to the
conclusion that they didn't have a c
blanch a green light from the United
States to do whatever they wanted and
guess what happened instead of leading
to chaos at least among those countries
in the Persian Gulf it led to far
greater degree of int Regional diplomacy
in which they started to resolve their
problems on their own ultimately that is
actually quite good for the United
States it good it's good for us if they
take on the burden of stability
themselves instead of Shifting it to
American
shoulders and I know a big piece of the
puzzle from your perspective is US Iran
relations it's your expertise and uh
you've been very critical
of America walking away from the Iran
nuclear deal under Trump Biden recently
froze billion in funds from Iranian oil
sales it's still unclear what exactly
Iran's role was in the Hamas attack but
we do know they've been issuing
continual threats to strike Israel if
they invade Gaza um is reproach with
Iran even conceivable at this point
given what's transpired what has
transpired has made it much much more
difficult but even before that it wasn't
that it was extremely difficult it
certainly was but it was no political
appetite for it in Washington nor in tan
so I did not expect anything to be able
to come out of any major diplomatic
moves uh between now and the election
this of course have made it much worse
and has potentially put a quiet
understanding between Iran and the
United States in Jeopardy as well a
quite understanding that would have led
to neither one of them actually
escalating matters with the other how
long that would last is unclear but I
think the administration's Hope was that
it would last at least until uh the
elections of November next year in some
ways that is good we don't need
escalating tensions on the other hand
it's a reflection of a very uh minimized
uh ambition level when it comes to this
we could have solved this issue if we
had continued to invest in the jcpa not
only because it would have stopped
Iranians from having 60% enrichment and
far greater amount of low Rich ranium
all things that were very problematic
that they have far more of now since we
left but also because it would have
potential other geopolitical
repercussions not everything that we
wanted but a lot of things including the
fact that I don't believe and I know
several people in the US government do
not believe that had the jcpa still been
in place had we been still a part of it
and it was fully implemented the
likelihood of the Iranians actually
supporting Russia in the invasion of
Ukraine would have gone down
significantly the cost benefit analysis
in ton would have been tremendously
different if they understood that they
risked the jcpa and some of the benefits
that they got from the jcpa if they
supported the Russians on this with the
jcpa gone that calculation of course
ended up being very different and now we
have them providing a tremendous amount
of support from drones and other things
to the Russians we wanted to just ask
you one last question and then let you
go because I know you have a heart out
pretty soon here you alluded at the very
beginning of this conversation to Iran's
domestic politics situation um I think
you were probably alluding to the Masa
protests which I have followed extremely
closely H could you just fill our
viewers in and give a little bit more
context about what has been happening in
Iran domestically for the last year or
so as well as what's been happening in
Lebanon I think having a little bit of
sense of what's going on domestically
can sometimes help people more fully
picture how a a regime how a leader will
respond internationally I think about
this a lot in terms of assessing the
degree to which a Chinese invasion of
Taiwan is likely and paying a lot of
attention to you know issues which he's
sort of being perceived as a little bit
weaker than he used to be um but talk
about the Masa protest talk about
domestic politics in Iran and then also
a little bit about Lebanon and then you
know you're welcome to head out all
right thank you so much
um the protest started last year in Iran
because the Iranian people had just had
it um they have been under so much
pressure economically partly as a result
of the exit of the jcpa by the United
States but also because of the
mismanagement and immense Corruption of
the Iranian regime itself of the economy
on top of that that summer the ri
government had started to tighten and
and make the implementation of certain
religious rules much stricter and then
you had the tragic death of ma Masa
Armenia which then sparked massive
protests uh that went on for months and
months and what was different about
these protests a really reflected that
the population at least at the time had
given up on the idea that there was a
way of reforming the Iranian system from
within that that pathway could lead to a
positive outcome and it was reflected
because they were no longer calling for
reforms or changes within the political
framework of Iran they were calling for
complete regime
change uh the regime showed tremendous
brutality clamped down on these protests
um and by and large was successful in
making sure that it it not end up
becoming that type of an existential
threat to the regime even though it's
still a very clear threat that has
already deprived the regime of the
little legitimacy it had in the first
place because the reaction of the regime
and the fact that this was over the
implementation of the head scarf even
had a tremendous amount of opposition
from conservative religious
conservatives in Iran who may have
chosen to wear the the hijab themselves
but were completely opposed to the idea
that it has to be mandatory or that the
regime has to use this type of brutality
to clamp down on it now a year later um
uh the the protest movement to a large
extent is not what it used to be and I
think to large large extent that is
because it lacked a clear leadership in
the first place uh movements of that
kind cannot take down a a government a
regime that is as entrenched as the
Iranian one and that is willing to use
brutality to the extent that the Iranian
one is without a much much clearer and
stronger structure so there was this
immense energy in society but no
leadership to channel it and be able to
really press the the um the regime and
force it to compromise and force it to
to make significant changes so in some
ways a lot of that energy uh was lost
now there's some changes that have
happened but they're not structural
changes a lot of people I talk to say
that you actually don't see women
wearing hijab in the same way as they
did before that in some ways they have
won that battle the implementation of it
is also not at all what it used to be I
mean the religious police is by and
large off the streets uh uh and are not
acting in in such a manner to be able to
spark in other protest but nothing has
changed in terms of the legislation of
the laws of the land so this could
easily be a tactical shift that the
regime is doing for now but then go back
to uh a much stricter implementation but
also perhaps even more importantly it
has deprived the the opposition from
being able to take this matter that was
centered on the hijab uh in the
beginning but to then transcend it to a
focus on the more fundamental structures
and the tremendous injustices that exist
in Iranian system now I think there is a
bit of um disillusionment because um uh
the population on the one hand had lost
faith in the idea of Reform and I think
many at this point have lost faith in
the idea of a revolutionist well where
this will go no one knows at this point
but one thing we can say is that the
Irani population by and large is
extremely unhappy with the situation and
definitely want to change the pathway to
that change however is unclear at this
point thank you so much for talking to
reason we really appreciate it um for
our live stream viewers Zach and I will
stay on and talk a little bit about some
of the US uh cultural domestic politics
response to this but thank you so much
trto Pary where can people find you in
the future they can find me at Trea
par.com or go to the website of the
Quincy Institute which is Quincy
ins.org
thank you TR
thank you so
much
find okay thank you sorry yep okay uh
I'm going to pull up a couple questions
that have come in and then as Liz
mentioned we'll shift to some further
discussion of some of the domestic
reactions
to the the the uh terrorist attack that
Hamas engaged in um one was from I'm I'm
pulling up two that for from kind of
opposite perspectives here one is El
harto hate to both sides this but yeah
both sides two bloodthirsty regimes are
tearing each other and the civilians
caught in the crossfire to shreds us has
nothing to gain from this
debacle I think that it's true that the
US has nothing to gain from this debacle
uh the the both sides aspect of this I
think the the misleading part of that is
that
there was clearly an aggressor in this
case it was a terrorist attack on
civilians from Hamas that's not to say
that Israel Israel's government has not
engaged in violent and repressive
activity leading up to this um or that
their response cannot be critiqued in
fact I think that uh Israel is not doing
all it could be doing to enable humanit
humanitarian corridors uh there's been
reports that you know they've been that
Israel I I mean Egypt has been trying to
negotiate with them to get supplies in
and they've faced a lot of resistance to
those
negotiations I understand kind throwing
up their hands and being like Oh well
we're not really going to do much in
terms of humanitarian Aid and being very
difficult to negotiate with so I do
think there's like an Egyptian role
there that sort of people aren't paying
as much attention to which is a little
weird to me you mean the fact that
Egypt's not willing to take in the
refugees the fact that they're not
willing to take in the refugees but then
also the fact that although the Rafa
border crossing is technically passable
um you know so you could get people out
via that border crossing or also Egypt
has the ability to supply humanitarian
Aid to Gaza um I think it's a little
wild that there's so much heat given to
Israel in terms of like hey you need to
like bring in food and water and fuel
and ensure that the generators stay
running in Gaza when it's like well
Egypt could also be playing a role here
there was that huge dispute a few days
ago related to the quality of screening
of the humanitarian Aid that is
literally assembled on the border right
now in Egypt waiting to enter Gaza and
Israel and Egypt are very much
loggerheads in terms of the method in
which the aid is going to be screened
for weapons uh which seems like a very
reasonable request on the part of the
state of Israel to basically be saying
hey we want to ensure that this isn't a
means of trafficking any weapons to
Hamas we want to make sure that this is
just literally food and water and fuel
and you know Egypt could sort of accede
to some of those demands I think it's a
little odd to me that there isn't more
blame place there yeah this is some of
the recent reporting on that matter that
you're referencing Liz this is from
Reuters talks fail to let Aid reach Gaza
Israel Evac evacuates Lebanon border and
uh Cairo is saying that the Rafa
Crossing was not officially closed but
was inoperable due to Israeli strikes on
the Gaza side and the Egyptian foreign
minister said there's an urgent need to
alleviate the suffering of Palestinian
civilians in Gaza adding that talks with
Israel on opening Rafa for Aid had been
so far fruitless but you're saying that
a lot of the the fruitlessness of that
has to do with security concerns well
completely and I mean so the so the the
border crossing was allegedly struck um
I believe like a week ago or more than a
week ago at this point and then
basically um in order to get the 500 or
so US citizens uh out of Gaza that are
trapped there basically the US
government said hey come down to the
Rafa border crossing this will be sort
of the only means of getting you out and
then the Egyptian government has
basically been like no we're not going
to permit that and so you had people
waiting at that border crossing you know
the appropriate window of time came and
went and they just thus far still have
not gotten out all of this transpired on
Saturday today is now Thursday and then
we also have this huge dispute between
um Israel and Egypt with which President
Biden claims to have brokered a deal and
you know until the aid literally passes
through the Border like that's when I'll
believe that this deal has actually
happened uh because there have been
quite a few news reports over the last
few days of Egypt and Israel reaching a
deal to get this humanitarian through
the border and finding something that is
mutually agreable in terms of screening
for weapons and Egypt hasn't really been
willing to work with Israel uh to come
to something that they both agree to so
I I just think it's like it's
legitimately a very like all sides are
doing something very bad right I think
there should be nothing bad about the
both sides ISM and the both sides
rhetoric because in many situations uh
in politics domestic and international
both sides or all sides are behaving
terribly right
yeah and this is one more comment I
wanted to bring up from railen Katz who
says occupation Israel pulled out of
Gaza in 2005 Hamas has ruled Gaza since
2006 both of which are
true however that's little that's not
very comforting for the civilians who
live in Gaza who are both under the
thumb of Hamas which has not held
elections for years and and also have
been subject to a blockade for most of
that time that limits their options so I
I
mean I'm not here to uh adjudicate or or
you know come up with what what the
perfect two-state solution is but
there's clearly reason for these
grievances that people both in in Gaza
and the West Bank have their their lives
are far from Pleasant
free well the thing that's kind of
interesting to me about this and I think
that this is frankly you know more of a
subject for a future live stream is we
keep hearing the rhetoric of open air
prison being thrown around to describe
what conditions in Gaza are like and
conditions you know especially right now
are atrocious horrible I mean you have
600,000 people who fled from North to
South uh astonishing you know numbers of
people displaced you have dwindling
numbers of hospitals where people can go
and seek medical care you have last
night I believe
uh the last like oncology unit able to
treat people's cancer and able to do
radiation treatments for people is is no
longer operational because of the crisis
of generators having run out of fuel
it's a horribly dire situation there but
I think the the thing that's kind of odd
is people keep fixing on the open air
prison concept and in reality the
situation for the last 16 years has
frankly been more like just a massive
sprawling refugee camp like there are
some parts that are actually relatively
I don't want to say wealthy but sort of
like you know acceptable but by and
large vast parts of Gaza are
legitimately more akin to refugee camps
and the thing that's really horrifying
is that I mean there are so many other
uh entities in the region I'm thinking
particularly is or particularly Egypt
that could decide to allow some sort of
influx of Gins through their borders
when times are as dire as they are and
there's been a little bit of mixed
messages from Al's government basically
saying that they are setting up some
refugee camps possibly in a few small
towns in Egypt but then also they're
sort of renigging on that and saying
nope nobody will be allowed to pass
through the border and I don't know I
think the role the Egypt is playing
honestly deserves more scrutiny here
although the perspective of of e
Egyptian the Egyptian government and
many Palestinians is that to enable a
sort of mass Exodus into Egypt or Jordan
which has also refused to take uh the
Palestinian refugees is that this would
be enabling I mean in their words an
ethnic cleansing that this is from their
perspective what Israel wants is to
clear the Palestinians out and send them
to the surrounding countries I mean do
you think there's any validity to that I
mean there there the IDF is caught
between a rock and a hard place right I
mean you had 1300 people brutally
murdered including 260 people at like a
peace loving Rave you had a bunch of uh
like kabut so people who live on Kut who
are frequently kind of like agricultural
left- wiish hippies like living in
community doing their little
experimental living thing I mean you had
Holocaust you had innocent people
brutally slaughtered on mass and then
frankly when dealing with Hamas you have
an entity that uses human Shields and
you know has even in the past conducted
some of their main operations beneath
alifa Hospital right so then that puts
Israel in a very tough spot because if
you actually do want to Target this
terrorist group Hamas to take them out
yet their tactics are entirely
predicated on ensuring that they're
centering their operations underneath
hospitals and in dense places and in you
know like these vast networks of
underground tunnels what exactly is the
approach to take them out uh you know I
think we all you know want to see less
and less innocent human life lost that's
something that's so essential to you
know the how I look at non-aggression
and my libertarianism right like any I
think the reason why so many of us are
non-interventionists is because we see
the massive human toll um that war takes
and see it as just a deeply abominable
thing uh that we should always and
everywhere oppose but there is also this
challenge of how is Israel supposed to
ensure that this terrorist group that
brutally murdered so many of their
people is taken out or or has their
operations crippled because this is very
much an unsustainable situation for them
I mean I don't I think that the IDF is
fairly as conscientious as one can be
while still being a military in terms of
attempting to you know for example drop
the little I don't know what the term
for it is but like the sort of like
warning um shots on tops of buildings to
indicate hey this is going to be where a
strike is taking place please like you
know get out of here flee uh and then
even things like ordering the evacuation
of Northern Gaza down to the South and
basically Hamas was telling people to
stay put but the IDF was very
specifically saying hey here is where
we're going to strike here is where
we're going to do a ground Invasion and
you you have a 24-hour deadline to get
out and then people didn't move some did
but not everybody Hamas kept telling
people to stay put and Israel kept
pushing back the time that they were
going to invade and they still haven't
done a ground Invasion like I'm sorry
but that looks to me like an attempt an
attempt however you know imperfect to to
lose as little innocent civilian life as
possible yeah but to treat a parse's
point I think that the way the role that
the US might play a little bit more is
to broker whether that's you know
directly or through its role in the UN
some sort of assurance because there's
an understandable suspicion I'll say
among Palestinians and the Arab world in
the way Palestinians have been treated
in the past and the way that
Palestinians have been you know there
there's been Exodus out to the
surrounding countries that's C that's
caused destabilization in these
countries it's also caused Palestinians
to leave and never really be be able to
come back or not really have citizenship
in this new country either so I think
that has to be taken into the equation
and any sort of agreement that is
brokered there needs to be assurances
that if we are exiting you out of here
to get you to safety a we're not going
to drop bombs uh near the border
checkpoint as you are headed to the
South 100% agree and B uh there's going
to be some sort of international
assurance that uh if if you're innocent
you're not affiliated with Hamas then
you you will be able to come back um I I
think that is probably driving a lot of
the fear it's it's going to be hard to
get that that message into Gaza at this
point but um you know these are when we
talk about non-interventionism you know
the the we what what we're focused on is
not trying to tilt overly tilt the
military balance One Direction or
another but diplomacy is still I think
an important role from a Libertarian
perspective for the US to broker I 100%
agree with you on that I think it's uh
you know I see from one of the comments
on here
um you know this what was it I catch a
little hint of War drumming uh by Jason
English and then he later commented just
surprised because a lot of this sounds a
little like CNN Fox NBC so on and I do
think that it is important to draw this
distinction you know I am I am not
interested in the US uh going to war
here uh in any way I think that Zach is
totally right in terms of the Diplomatic
role the US can play in brokering a
peace deal the thing that I think is
really tough though is sometimes I think
from the libertarian perspective you
have a certain I don't know sometimes
there's a people are a little
unrealistic in terms of basically saying
pull out any amount of you know pull out
all us support of Israel pull out all us
Aid pull out all us diplomacy and it's
like well but surely from the role that
the US currently plays to the
aspirational role that we want it to
play there are a whole bunch of sort of
incremental steps that must happen along
the way uh and I think it's important to
take those types of things seriously and
to still maintain this idea that like
loss of life um you know frankly wasting
US taxpayer money all of these things
are horrible in the US has a long track
record of sinting in this realm uh in
many different places over many
different decades but I also do think
it's important to take seriously this
question of well us involvement aside
what is Justified like does Israel have
any sort of like self-defense type
justification here I don't think there
are any easy answers to this question
and the person who I actually think has
grappled with this um most successfully
uh on the recent Mass head has actually
been our editor-in chief Katherine mangu
Ward on reason's Roundtable I think
there's a lot of knowledge of the
history here but also a comfort in
saying there are no easy answers here
and even sometimes libertarianism
doesn't perfectly inform like what the
state of Israel is Justified in doing
right it gives us a little bit of a
better sense of what the US's role in
relation to these other countries ought
to be but I think it's a very thorny
issue I mean fundamentally the fact that
these terrorist groups exist uh and have
murdered by and large uh peaceful and
innocent people uh in Israel is just I
mean it's it's profoundly devastating
and and it's very possible that many of
the actions that the US takes in the
future will also be devastating right
like I think committing troops to this
situation um or making clumsy diplomatic
missteps or wasting a ton of taxpayer
dollars that we don't have to spend
would also be really devastating so I
think it's likely that lots of people
will end up losers in this I think
that's for sure and the problem with you
know it Israel should have like any
country a right or not a right but the
the military is
Justified in offering defense and
self-defense when attacked and the
US I think to the greatest degree
possible should not be putting its
finger on the scale one way or another
but the fact is that we are doing that
and we heard Biden make the announcement
in the speech and went over the amount
of money and military aid that the us is
going to continue to supply to Israel so
whe whether you and I like that or think
that's the right move or not that that
is the fact that the US is backing
Israel and so to one degree or another
whatever they do is going to be a
reflection on US foreign policy as well
completely I mean I see the I see the
role of Libertarians as sort of
two-prong right like on one hand we
articulate an aspiration of what we want
the future to be and then on the other
hand we also engage with the world as it
currently is which is frequently very
very far from the libertarian ideal and
it's tough because I think in this
conversation even like you and I I think
surely exact same aims of of how the US
um ultimately becomes less involved in
this conflict and serves less as the
world's policeman or ideally doesn't
serve as the world's policeman at all um
but there is this question of like well
when we're how do you extricate yourself
when you're already in so far you know
when you're in this this far right and I
think the fact of the matter is we're
going to see so much horrific political
posturing and Nikki Haley's probably
going to beat her War honger is Real
Drum in the next debate and we're going
to have to host a therapy session for
Zack afterwards because he will
absolutely hate every second of it let
me turn us to what we talked about a
little bit last week the ways in which
many American activists have framed
hamas's attack on Israel because I think
you and I are at complete agreement on
this point I want to revisit the
conversation with a clip from this past
weekend of a Cornell professor
expressing the exhilaration he says he
felt after that attack happened let's
roll
that what hasas
doneas has shifted the balance of
power Hamas has
punctured the
illusion of
invisibility there are many
dos of
goodwi many I
conscious who
violence as you as who have the
targeting of civilians as do you as do
I who were able to
breathe they were able to
breathe for the first time in
years it was exhilerating
it wasting
wasinger by this this challenge to the
Monopoly of Violence by this shifting of
the balance of power then they would not
human
[Music]
wasil
first let me just say that I hear
complaints that harping on the stuff
from Le Lefty activists and professors
is not as important as what's happening
in Israel and Gaza and that is
absolutely true but the reason I think
it's worth talking about is because it's
a real mask off moment for the social
justice left they they use all these
academic terms decolonialization
Shifting the power Dynamic but but we
are now seeing in practice what all of
that means it means we're okay with
killing innocent people non-combatants
maybe we won't do it ourselves maybe
we'll throat clear before but we'll
excuse it just like how we excuse the
Looting and destruction in the summer of
2020 with this outof context MLK quote
about riots as the voice of the unheard
and it's just been years of
microaggression silence is violence
punch fascist
and fascists is like everyone to the
right of Hugo Chavez that's what I hear
with this rhetoric you're giving
permission to cheer Slaughter and as
long as you're on the wrong side of the
simplistic oppressor oppressed dichotomy
we're going to shrug at best when it
happens and you know you can criticize
Israel's government all you want and
they they should be criticized I've
criticized them some today but you don't
make excuses for barbaric killing
because you agree with the cause and
it's just asking for something really
ugly to happen in this country and when
it does part of that is going to be on
people like that guy you're supposed to
be an intellectual role model so start
acting like
it yeah I mean my thoughts on this are a
very strong and concise that guy um
there is no excuse for that type of
thing nothing about watching innocent
people be murdered was exhilarating
nothing about that was exciting it was
Despicable it was a horrible un proved
senseless act of violence and it's
really stunning to me that people all
across college campuses sometimes at
very elite schools you know we have this
happening at Cornell we have this
happening at Harvard uh we have this
happening at the University of
Pennsylvania the degree to which the
left has consistently um you know the
far-left the progressive woke campus
activists and academics have really
shown themselves to be simplistic in
their understandings of foreign policy
uh simplistic in their understandings of
race relations simplistic in sort of
promulgating their colonizer narratives
acting as if you know basically the
racial Dynamics and colonist dynamics of
the United States can be mapped on to
every other area in the world which is
obviously patently false I mean for
about nine years now these same people
have been shouting about
microaggressions and the need for safe
spaces and shouting down campus speakers
um in one case I remember I think it was
the middleberry case where they ended up
also like assaulting a a uh the person
it was the Charles Murray Allison
Stanger talk they ended up assaulting
Allison uh who by the way was the sort
of slightly more Lefty person presented
as the foil the person there to
challenge Charles Murray um so you
literally in some cases have these
campus uh speaker shout Downs that are
resulting in actual violence and yet
these are the same people who want to
act like the littlest thing is a
microaggression I'm sorry this is a fu
macroaggression you don't get to
stand on stage and you know talk about
how exhilarating it is to see people be
brutally raped and murdered uh it's it's
I I wonder whether this will be the
moment that the radical campus and
academic left breaks it feels like the
cracks have been forming it feels like
some of the grift and Corruption present
in the black lives matter organization
and the higher-ups like Patrice kers it
seems like people have really lost some
faith in that um we also saw a lot of
sort of Hamas paraglider graphic design
uh co-opting by BLM and by DSA groups in
the US I wonder whether DSA black lives
matter and some of these woke campus
groups will sort of completely lose
credibility forever because of this
moment I think it's very possible I mean
it's already becoming a liability
because employers are trying to ask if
you are affiliated with this group or
that group that did that and you you
know I'm not someone who is for that
kind of oppressive we might call cancel
culture uh but the to the degree that it
does become a
liability I think that that there's an
there's there's enough of a backlash
where we we might start to see a little
bit of that unwind but whether it does
or not I mean it we need people to stand
against that and call that crap out
because we have to defend like the
liberal Society we have to defend the
idea that it's not acceptable to violate
people's rights and their life and their
property just because they happen to be
in a disfavored group that's just like a
fundamental Bedrock of what this whole
thing is supposed to be about and these
people it it's reached a breaking point
for me at least uh with this like that
um they are eroding that just really
fundamental bedrock and by the way his
assertion that uh oh it's so exciting
exhilarating to see this power Dynamic
flip
like flipped I mean uh Israel is uh
annihilating Hamas and the Gaza Strip is
never going to be the same after like
there there hasn't been some sort of
like amazing shift in power like we
learned talking to Max Abrams last week
terrorist attacks like this they don't
achieve their political objective and
the hamas's political objective is not
to help the people in Gaza or the West
Bank at least in the short term it's to
bolster their image and put them at the
center of some bigger movement and
they'll they'll rack up as much
collateral damage as they need to to do
so so this is a really just
disappointing and frustrating moment I
honestly feel like this is the second
installment
of the summer of George Floyd like do
you remember that moment in 2020 after
George Floyd was brutally killed by cops
and were Libertarians we completely uh
reject the fact that so much police
abusive power exists and that type of
thing is is absolutely horrific to watch
um you know reasons Billy ban and C.J
camel have done excellent reporting on
this but right after that happened there
were all of those crazy protests some of
which are protests a lot of them were
riots uh and you you remember I mean
it's it's now a a an internet meme uh
the idea of the mostly peaceful protest
and it was like you know some anchor
talking about this as you know fires
were burning in the background right
behind it right like these were riots
and there was enormous uh property
destruction uh that resulted from this
and on one hand you could say people
have every right to to protest this
horrific police killing uh but they uh
ended up really savaging American cities
I mean it was awful you had shop Windows
being boarded up
uh as if that's the sign of a
functioning healthy democracy it was
really sad and I think for a lot of
people it was this moment where there
was like a oh this isn't just advocating
for police reform this isn't just
advocating for you know specific changes
to qualified immunity right like this is
people engaging in these really brutal
and sometimes violent methods of trying
to get what they want politically um
from the left I'm like that's not
something that we like they sort of
showed themselves a little bit and I
wonder whether we're currently seeing
this in this current moment where
there's an awful lot of I think
legitimate anti-Semitism coming out and
um a sense that I'm getting from some
far-left Progressive activists that they
authentically think that you know for
people who they consider to be oppressed
it is perfectly okay to use violence to
achieve the ends that they desire and I
disagree with that and I think many
normal people on the left disagree with
that I I I wonder what will happen uh
and whether these Progressive far-
leftist ideals and talking points and
groups will continue to exist for years
to come or whether they will just lose
credibility on mass as a result of this
well and I hope that they realize the
degree to which they are tainting these
conversations and the ability to have to
advocate for police reform which is
necessary none none of us thought it was
okay for Derek schin to kneel on this
guy until he died and I'm glad that this
this man is in prison
and I continue to be a believer in and
advocate for Criminal Justice Reform and
and police being held accountable for
their actions and people not being
sentenced to decades and decades in
prison uh what they shouldn't be and
similarly I have so sympathy for aspects
of the Palestinian cause it's partly why
I wanted to have tra on here today to
try to flesh that out a little bit and
explain
a little bit of the the history and the
Grievances I think it's not completely
without Merit but when you are embracing
or you know elevating this iconography
it it taints the conversation and it it
just makes it that much harder to to
make any progress on these issues and
I'm hoping that the kinds of the
conversations we're trying to host here
where it's a little less heated uh and a
little less Reliant on slogans that we
can advance that uh and I I really
appreciate your participation in that
project Liz and I and both TR parcy who
joined us this week and Max Abrams the
week before and we're going to continue
that conversation uh in the weeks to
come and I hope that all of you who
participated live today and who listened
after the fact will tune in again next
week same time Thursday one o'clock
Eastern thank you so much we will see
you then